hi welcome to designing google
kubernetes clusters for massive scale
and performance session where we will
talk how Google and Twitter joined
forces to push the limits of what DK and
kubernetes technologies can do and will
also give you a set of best practices
how to think about running at large
scale with good reliability and
performance I'm a magical jockey and I'm
a product manager at Google hi and I'm
Reza Motamedi and I'm a software
engineer at Twitter first off as we're
going to talk about scalability let's
nail down the definition of what it
actually means if you scan the internet
for explanations what scalability is
you'll find numerous definitions but
they all boil down to a characteristics
characteristic or capability of a system
to work with a very significant amount
of resources while still being able to
operate with reliability performance and
essentially do the job that the system
was meant to do when it comes to
kubernetes we expect that in most use
cases you want to run on more than one
cluster to mega minimize the risk of any
potential blast radius problems with any
outages still being able to operate also
large clusters will simplify as many
parts of how you're managing your
software starting from easier ability to
manage the micro services that you
running for example by avoiding the need
for excessive sharding to reduce
operating operational toil on managing a
fleet of clusters there are also
scenarios were simply running on a
single very large cluster makes the most
sense for example for highly
parallelizable batch jobs and last but
not least it's very useful in many cases
to be able to operate in the lower
bounds of what a particular technology
can do like kubernetes and have a buffer
to the scale limits
of it so that you can absorb large
spikes for example when you're running
an e-commerce store and from time to
time you have very significant spikes
coming from sales or events like that
Friday when you think about companies
that run at massive scale and operate
very huge infrastructure twitter is
going to be the one of the largest in
the world so let's listen from Reza how
they are maintaining their
infrastructure and how they think about
its evolution in the future thanks MA
check I'm going to briefly talk about
the compute infrastructure at Twitter
where we are today and where we're going
and how kubernetes in general and jke
specifically fits into our plans the
current main compute offering a twitter
is powered by mesas cluster manager and
Aero scheduler twitter embraced
containers starting in 2012 we use super
lightweight containers with Linux II
groups we're not using virtual machine
or darker level containers but the C
groups we are able to co-locate most of
the were closed the on computer
infrastructure currently our compute
offering is mostly on-premise but we are
extending it with computing cloud our
customers who are Twitter engineers hire
us to manage the lifecycle of their
micro services that as a whole power the
Twitter conversation platform there are
different categories of these micro
services
first there are stateless application
these are mostly fault tolerant
real-time services that are very
sensitive to latency there's also a
sizable amount of offline password load
mostly doing machine learning which is
also stateless second we have services
that are kind of stateful meaning they
keep some sort of state but the state is
not generally durable these includes
caches and search indices and other
services like that these services are
not so forgiving in the face of failure
so for them both performance and
platform relies
he is important it is also important to
note that compute infrastructure was
built from the ground up to be
multi-tenant so most microservices live
in the same shared pool we generally
like multi-tenancy because it scales in
multiple directions from resource
efficiency to operational efficiency and
also helps us with capacity management
the key win for compute team has been
that all these different services used
the same configuration deployment
debugging and management interfaces this
allows us to build the tooling on top of
a single platform that benefit all
engineering teams at Twitter in terms of
scale we run a smaller number of large
mesas clusters each compute cluster has
in the order of millions of CPU cores
hundreds of thousands of containers tens
of thousands of hosts
and thousands of services are running on
each cluster our micro services have
also adapted to our large clusters
meaning that we host more than a few
services that each have thousands of
instances in terms of operation we
manage and maintain all of our clusters
with only 10 to 15 software and
reliability engineers with that intro
let's see where Twitter wants to go from
here and how that affects our plans for
the compute team there is Twitter's main
mission is to serve the public global
conversation for this we need to
complement our own on-premise compute
infrastructure with offerings from
public cloud providers we already
leverage public cloud for some workloads
for example those that benefit from
global distribution and we expect this
trend to increase over time but as we
explore using the cloud we don't want
our customers to deal with fragmented
computer interfaces both in on-premise
and in the cloud so our goal is to keep
providing a unified experience to
Twitter engineers
also as we run compute platform in more
environment that offer new primitives we
see new opportunities we we can extend
this standard micro service management
layer that we have today across an even
more diverse set of services this means
that we can onboard the remaining
services onto our platform for example
stateful stateful services that are
running on bare metal today this will
basically improve developers experience
and productivity and will eventually
reduce the run the business costs for
everyone at Twitter to deal with the
potential additional complexity the
compute team did a detailed evaluation
and selected kubernetes as the
technology that would power the next
generation to their compute platform
both in cloud and on-premise this
simplifies our job since compute team
needs to be expert in man and manage a
single technology and provides a unified
experience to our customers regardless
of where their services are running it
also gives us the benefit of the benefit
and support of a vibrant open source
community but all this means that
kubernetes and gke had to scale to
Twitter needs at least to some extent
for an acceptable migration path so
having heard the requirements and the
needs of Twitter we set off to push the
limits of what our technology can offer
and meet the requirements of of Twitter
now as we set off to document those
requirements first I'd like to explain
to you the framework that we use to
document the requirements and
scalability of kubernetes in general
it's a framework that we use in this
context but we also recommend that you
leverage it as you also think about your
architecture whether in the initial
phases or as you're diagnosing an
existing
growing system a very frequently when we
talk about kubernetes scale we use the
number of nodes as a proxy to describe
in a simplified fashion the scale of the
cluster as your workloads growing
complexity this becomes insufficient you
may have scenarios where you don't use
too many nodes but still hits
scalability problems for example if you
excessively use services in your cluster
so a better way to think about your
clusters and workloads is through a
multi-dimensional hypercube where on
each of the dimensions you describe the
resources that your clusters and
workloads need and on all of those
dimensions there will be an envelope
that wraps all of the acceptable
configurations where if you don't break
those limits and don't go beyond that
envelope we will be able to say that
your cluster is you're faster scales so
it can use the resources that you need
and it gives a healthy service to your
users the dimensions that you can see
here on the screen are just examples
there is many many more that you should
account for you can find them in our
documentation of various materials and
the topic here we want to essentially
explain the concept how to think about
this also there might be dimensions that
will be very unique and specific to your
particular workload with the abstraction
layers and extensions that you will add
to your cluster I would like to draw
your attention to a couple of
characteristics of the scalability
envelope for kubernetes that are very
important to anything about scaling your
workloads first of all the dimensions of
that cube are depend on one another so
and moreover the functions that describe
those dependencies are not linear and
frequently or somewhat convex for
example you can theoretically run a
hundred and ten pots on every node but
if you grow your cluster too much they
move additional nodes the acceptable
port density will be very quickly going
down and large clusters you will not be
able to go up of 30 pots by node
the envelope tapers along today each
axis which means that if you excessively
use a particular resource on your
cluster then you will get much less
freedom on all of the other dimensions
with your workloads the whole envelope
is bounded primarily by the limits of
how much detail you can store on that CD
so there are points that you cannot just
break with by stretching the envelope
edges on one dimension but what's pretty
positive about the behavior of this
envelope is that it's decomposable into
smaller ones so there are subsets of
dimensions with which you can play
independently from other subsets and
this way taken simplified approach to
analyzing your architecture so big
equipped with this framework of
describing requirements we documented
the needs of Twitter we also engaged a
few other design partners and we worked
with a broad group of customers and
users who we know could benefit from
operating at large larger scale than
currently supported and kubernetes and
based on that analysis we came up with a
set of generic solutions our portfolio
of use cases in which we believe users
really need very large scale and we have
an understanding of how the various
dependencies between dimensions need to
be pushed so that we offer a very good
end to end experience fall of the
workloads that users would be Roenick on
those clusters that equipped us to set a
set of targets where we want to push the
existing limits of the technology
forward to meet the needs of more and
more demanding users the primary
dimension that we decided to improve and
move is the number of nodes up to 15,000
so freedom is bigger than the currently
supported limit in terms of the number
of God's it's half a million by cluster
we also invested heavily into improving
the various characteristics of
networking components in kubernetes
locks storing using very large services
and many many other
aspects of of how you run on Craster's
you can look for details in our
documentation we'll publish more
specific information about each
dimension to effectively work on pushing
the limits of the technology we
augmented and extended our testing
framework through additional license
laws extending the tests yield with
additional benchmark workloads both
synthetic and emulating real customer
scenarios so that along the way as we're
progressing towards pushing the limits
of the technology we are we are able to
effectively diagnose where we are on
that journey and are we already able to
offer highly reliable and scalable
service to our customers the
improvements that we implemented on that
journey come in a few areas the main one
which is probably also the most obvious
is the fact that the kubernetes open
sourced software required a lot of
tuning and improvements that we
implemented added to the opera
source-based stack there was a lot of
performance optimizations in various
components all over the codebase plus we
added new EPL's which were designed from
ground up to support large scale and big
clusters we collaborated very deeply
with communities that manage products on
which kubernetes depends on primarily
here at CD and go lock to improve the
performance that they offer to
kubernetes and we made huge investments
into the integration layers between
kubernetes pastures and jiseop is
infrastructure so a lot of work went
into improved logging and monitoring
pipelines auto-scaling capabilities
networking components our control plane
its ability to configure and create
clusters and manage their configuration
as they grow in scale with all of these
improvements implemented and our tests
to diagnose how it goes as we realized
that we built built a product that we
meat algorithms of our customers we went
back to Twitter to get their feedback
whether indeed the high-performance
build of je that we created mystery
needs and will be usable for them so as
we heard could Google has invested in
rigorous scale testing of kubernetes in
general and specifically gke but twitter
was very much interested in running its
own scale test mainly for a couple of
reasons first as matric previously
mentioned each workload profile is
unique specifically for Twitter
workloads we were interested in scaling
nodes and pods and namespaces and number
of secret dimensions but we were not
interested in unit using some other
resources like services and config maps
at least for now this might have not
been a scenario that Google had scale
tested for second we wanted the services
running on gke to work seamlessly with
services running on our current compute
setup on premise so we decided to use
plug ability and extensibility features
in kubernetes and somewhat heavily
customize the control plane we wanted to
run our own scale test to make sure that
our customization will also stay stable
at scale to come up with a test plan we
followed our migration strategy we
decided to create workload that would
closely resemble what Twitter will
eventually run in kubernetes on Prem and
also in gke we started with what we are
currently running on Arora mesas
clusters but these clusters are at least
three times larger than the theoretical
maximum kubernetes cluster sizes so we
split the services and batch jobs
running gonna make those cluster across
3G K clusters as we mentioned before
adopting kubernetes gave us an
opportunity to run other type of
application on compute as well for
instance stateful applications that are
currently running as bare metal services
can onboard kubernetes as stateful sets
and host level services are used for
host level upgrades accountant
distribution in auditing can be deployed
as demon sets in short we profiled
what's running on our current large data
centers and we spread them across
smaller kubernetes clusters we wanted to
make the migration to kubernetes and
cloud seamless to our engineers so we
had to customize kubernetes control
plane to make gke integrated with our on
premise infrastructure we created a set
of custom controllers and Admission web
hooks for this and I'm gonna go over a
subset of the customization that we did
here we created a Twitter set controller
a Twitter set is a hybrid between
stateful send and a deployment in
kubernetes terminology and we expect all
Twitter micro services to run as a
Twitter set it provides stable numerical
instance identifier similar to stateful
set but it allows us to do batch update
similar to how deployments work each
Twitter set can have multiple
configuration per workload which is
mostly used at Twitter for Canarian
changes and it also provides us with
rollback on update failure which is
similar to how Aurora scheduler
performed its updates today we also have
a few mediating and validating web hooks
mostly to enforce consisting naming and
labeling standards and also to enforce
security policies for instance we don't
want to allow foreign docker images in
our clusters we also have a note ready
controller whose job is basically to
taint notes that do not run all they
expected demons on them after an
analysis on the current on-premise
workload we arrived at the following
test targets we targeted 15,000 notes
600 namespaces we added 60,000 secrets
that are not evenly distributed among
all the namespaces we estimated that we
are going to run three demon sets and 10
stateful sets with a total of 8,000
parts we added around 400 cron jobs and
this added another
four thousand pods [ __ ] we finally added
four thousand Twitter set which added
another eighty thousand parts to the
entire workload so what does scale test
look like could minimize the inner test
interference each test run starts from
the blank slate and goes to the
following step we create a new cluster
we apply to other customizations we set
up some monitoring we apply the workload
and finally be collected results we
measured these results in terms of
service level objectives or some s ellos
we carried some of these s ellos from
our current compute setup since our
customers are pretty much used to them
although in practice these RS ellos
highly depend on workload configuration
they give us a good baseline for
comparison I focus here on 2's ellos
here that are demonstrated in this
diagram time to update for Twitter said
in short we call it t tu and time to
running for a part that is called a T TR
in short as the name suggests TT u is
the time it takes for a Twitter set to
be fully rolled up this obviously
depends on the batch size in the rolling
update strategy for the Twitter set in
our test we set that to be 20% of the
size of the workload which is a common
practice among our engineers we targeted
median t tu to be below 10 SEC 10
minutes for a Twitter set of size of
5,000 replicas time to running for a
part is a time between a pod update is
requested until it is considered running
after its update is finish as a diagram
shows this also includes some overhead
for deleting the old pod in addition to
a minimum ready second which is a
setting that you can set in your pod
spec and we set that to be 10 seconds
and we targeted this SLO to have a
median of below 40 seconds so with that
let's look at some results we have the
time to running for part shown as a
histogram on the left and time to update
for different sizes of two
sets across different measurement as a
scatterplot on the right we see that 95%
of the pause are transitioning to
running in less than two minutes
note that this actually includes that
forty second baseline overhead
thirty Seconds for pot the leaf grace
period and ten seconds for minimum ready
seconds in our test setup given the
baseline we see that mean time it's
running is 29 seconds which is within
bound we also see that the largest to
intercept at 5000 replicas takes on
average seven minutes to update which is
again within our 10 minutes SLO bomb so
what did we learn from all of these
tests in many cases we benefited from
sharing our requirements early on with
Google this also helped Google with
prioritizing future work another point
we learned was that CR DS are not stored
as days are stored as JSON and not
protobuf struts this is not very
efficient when you're storing large
objects but there are a few tricks that
you can use here I you can break up a
large C or D if it contains a large
array into slices this is similar to how
endpoint slices work in release version
117 we also identified some optimization
points by just tuning some configuration
and no code changes for instance we
optimized the client go that we run we
use it inside our Twitter set controller
by setting the q PS and burst to improve
its performance we also reduce the load
on the web server that we have by
scoping the web configuration to only
look at namespace resources and this was
done to avoid the flood of note level
events so as we wrap up I'm gonna give
it back to magic to talk about some key
recommendations for you if you are
preparing to run large-scale clusters
thanks Reza so let's take a look at a
couple of recommended practices when you
think about planning and running your
own systems at a very large scale as you
could hear it's important that when that
you test and stretch both in the
planning phase and also in later
execution when you're testing and
building your systems you see how you in
particular will stretch the envelope you
need to see how your unique workload
stretchers kubernetes scalability
envelope and also see whether you're not
adding any additional abstraction layers
or specific flavors to the workload that
would apply only to you and so it
requires additional level of validation
whether it will operate at large scale
you can definitely rely on us to test a
set of negative to validate all of the
native components and set test the set a
set of representative workloads so that
we really verify that the infrastructure
layer that you're going to use is going
to offer high scalability when you think
about which aspects of your clusters and
work out you should look into definitely
validate how are you going to use all of
the native kubernetes resources whether
you're not going to hit any damage that
we documented and published see how all
of the customizations perform that you
install especially monitor what's the
load and impact that they exert on the
API server and make sure they operate
effectively at large scale see also how
your application itself performs at
large scale whether it like your points
and deployments are truly horizontally
scalable or there aren't any bottlenecks
that surface when you run at large scale
you should also remember that your
clusters who most cases will not exist
in void they will interact with other
products in your IT infrastructure and
they will exert significant load on some
of them so proper configuration for
example of databases that your stateless
micro services might be interacting with
is
very important to think about what in
planning and later in execution as your
systems grow to effectively monitor the
health of your systems you need to
define a set of a set laws that build
upon the standard ones that we measure
and are closer to what your end-users
need and how they perceive a reliability
of your system and that will give you a
proper framework to monitor
infrastructure that you're operating and
test and iterate if he to make any
improvements into it there is one area
of your systems architecture that I
would like to give you a closer look on
that we did not cover before which is
networking it's very important that you
look at how your whole network layers
design looks like and monitor also how
it evolves over time as your systems
grow and change particularly all of the
load balancing concepts irrespective
whether you using kubernetes Natick
native you're using the ones that are
provided by google cloud or you bring
your own load balancers they will have a
certain scalability and performance
characteristics that you take a look at
like total number of endpoints cheran
that they support or order you also need
to account for the efficiency and
performance of your dns if you operate
and use the units at large scale
definitely use not local caching IP
management is very important to get
right both on small and large clusters
but on large clusters that's even more
impactful as wrong IP spaces
configuration can be either lead to your
clusters not being able to grow beyond
certain limits or on the other hand
possibly using excessive amount of IPs
without the necessity for that as last
recommendation here in this context we
always recommend that you use regional
clusters for production and for large
scale private ones that offers the best
reliability availability and best
network throughput between the class no
master nodes and the rest of the cluster
whenever you get any problems or you
have any doubts please reach out to us
your account team or our support team or
the first line of communication that you
can engage with and they will involve
broader groups at Google that will be
very happy to step in and help you at
any stage at which you might be with
your work at running a large-scale you
brought up I wanted to make a couple of
final remarks as you could hear fifteen
thousand nodes are coming to gke we will
be rolling them out on top of release
118 we'd be very happy if you decided to
use them and we're very eager to hear
any feedback you might have about them
we if you have any questions we feel
free to use the Dory and also here on
the slide you can see our tutor he'll
also send us a direct message with that
we wanted to thank you and wish you good
luck at running a large scale and I also
wanted to thank you for tuning to our
video session